[Applaudissements]
le voyage est un retour vers l'essentiel
eu la chance de faire deux tours du
monde d'aller dans plus de 65 pays et à
la question c'est quoi vos rêves
d'avenir pour le monde de demain
j'ai toujours eu cette même réponse
quelles que soient les croyances un
monde plus juste plus solidaire plus
humain plus harmonieux alors ici c'était
ça notre rêve universel
le rêve de l'humanité dans son
intégralité puisse faire l'unanimité
pour la première fois dans son histoire
l'humanité et enfin la une et elle a
mûri
elle peut prendre conscience de son
passé et regarder 20 même oeil son futur
en se disant que si l'histoire se répète
peut-être pas la planète et qu'on n'est
pas encore seul sur mars mais ensemble
sur terre alors on fait quoi on fait
quoi ensemble on fait quoi ensemble
maintenant parce qu'on est face à notre
destin
on est face à un réel changement de
civilisation dizaines d'arbres où on est
à l'aube d'une possible crise financière
sociétal écologique religieuse ou le
progrès sur fond de néo libéralisme
ultra capitaliste transhumanistes des
populistes ne rime plus à grand chose et
où toute une génération était au bord du
burn out et on a quasiment réussi à tout
dématérialisé sauf le bonheur alors
j'aimerais qu'on fasse une pause une
pause prose et proposer autre chose et
oser proposer la métamorphose du cosmos
en osmose pas pour changer le cours de
bourse mais pour changer le cours de
l'histoire et qu'on passe de l'histoire
au futur de la modernité à la fraternité
avec un autre scénario qui puisse
célébrer la vie en global et l'humanité
dans un projet commun un avenir qui
donne envie d'en vie de mettre le cap
sur l'harmonie moi je suis un poète un
homme de lettres
en deux mots un type poétique officer
j'ai fondé une odyssée humaine la
pelouse du futur et ça fait dix ans que
j'ai un mot préféré c'est le mot
harmonie des rencontres et à un moment
donné de ma vie où j'avais pas forcément
besoin de mettre de l'ordre dans m mais
de l'harmonie et ça a changé ma vision
de l'est et pour moi c'est le mot le
plus essentiel le plus fondamental pour
l'humanité parce que c'est le mot le
plus doué et le plus puissant le plus
convergents le plus tolérant le plus
fluide le plus naturel plus humaniste le
plus reliant le plus interdépendant le
plus inspirant et le plus apaisant
l'harmonie l'harmonie en matière de soin
l'harmonie avec autrui avec la nature
dans les organisations avec les galaxy
dans l'être le faire le vivre ensemble
pour prendre soin de soi des autres et
de la terre même quand on décompose le
mot ça donne l'humanité ça donne
l'humain en amour qui rêvent d'un monde
en osmose avec le nous dans l'invisible
des étoiles l'humain en amour qui rêvent
d'un monde en osmose avec le nous dans
l'invisible des étoiles et là je me sens
déjà mieux je sais pas vous mais choses
simples plus apaisant en fin de compte
l'harmonie c'est c'est la musique de la
vie en grec ancien d'ailleurs ça veut
dire union agrément unités accord donc
c'est le fait de trouver un accord
ensemble
j'ai essayé de regarder s'il y avait
d'autres mots plus essentielles plus
important pour le monde
la vérité oui mais il ya 7 milliards de
réalité l'amour oui mais il ya cette
part d'instabilité et si ce n'est
l'amour inconditionnel universel
la raison mais je préfère être heureux
que avoir raison dieu aime avec les
guerres de religion peut-être alors dans
ce cas là le le divin intérieur de
chacun d'entre nous l'humanité oui mais
les autres espèces vivantes
la vie oui mais dans le respect des
libertés d'autrui déséquilibre obtient
un plus dans le noir muni moi c'est le
compromis
ces dénominateurs communs et donc
larmonier 1 où le maître mot clé de vie
pour l'avenir comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait tout mettre en oeuvre pour que
le monde de demain soir en plus de ces
accords et de ses mélodies pour qu'on
puisse ensemble vivre paisiblement vivre
et laisser vivre
on disait que le bonheur c'est quand nos
pensées nos paroles et nos actes sont en
harmonie et d'ailleurs et si c'était ça
le point g de l'humanité par monye le
point génial de l'humanité ce point
d'équilibré
ce cinquième élément ce moment où les
planètes sont alignées la synthèse de
tout cet accord qui donne le la du champ
de tous les possibles
cette ce consensus dans la cohérence à
la fois à titre personnel et collectif
d'ailleurs personnel parce que c'est
comme ça qu'on peut potentiellement
connecter les tons que son profil ses
talents ses vertus ses forces pour
ensuite trouver sa voie et trouver sa
place à l'intérieur du puzzle de
l'humanité et aussi pour que l'humanité
pucelle passer de son statut de ou sa
nature originelle
d'animal sociale guidés par la loi du
plus fort à son essence profonde d'être
de conscience dans l'art de vivre
ensemble moi c'est ça le ce point d
équilibre qui puisse satisfaire tout le
monde pour que le bonheur des uns
puissent faire aussi le bonheur des
autres et que chacun on puisse faire
notre part de colibri connaissez cette
légende amérindienne moi la meilleure
métaphore de ce siècle où un petit
colibri avec ses trois petites buttes
essaye d'éteindre l'incendié en disant
je fais ma part parce qu'on se pose tous
à peu près cette question là est souvent
laissées sans réponse d'ailleurs moi
plus le monde égalent quelle est ma
vraie fonction nous plus la terre égal
qu'elle est ma raison d'être
et dans ce cas là c'est ce serait pas ça
la voie médiane la voie du juste milieu
où une voie accessible à tous soit pas
radical mais avec un petit sacrifice de
chacun qui puisse donner un bénéfice
global plus important c'est comme la
savez cette fable de la fontaine la
cigale et la fourmi
pourquoi est-ce qu'on sera obligé de
choisir entre une cigale qui dansent
tout l'été et une fourmi qui va
travailler pour préparer ces vivres pour
l'hiver quoi ce qu'on pourrait pas être
les deux en même temps c'est à dire
vivre pleinement le présent tout en
préparant l'avenir
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait contribuer
à l'humanité tout en se réalisant en
même temps c'est ça le compromis comme
la notion d'utopie par exemple on dit
que c'est quelque chose d'irréalisable
non victor hugo disait que l'utopie
c'est la vérité de demain
moi j'aime à dire que l'utopie c'est
impossible à venir pas impossible à
venir est-ce que tout part du rêve alors
octroyons nous le droit de rêver et
d'imaginer notre futur pour ça que
autant j'adore la démocratie française
de triptyque liberté égalité fraternité
le drapeau bleu-blanc-rouge hymne de la
marseillaise mais je préfère militer
pour une république de l'harmonie avec
un triptyque politique poétique
politique un drapeau arc en ciel
pleurait den un hymne de la citoyenne
allant enfants de l'harmonie le jour de
choix est arrivé aux armes citoyens
je veux pas un business model jeune
entreprise modem je pas mesuré le taux
de croissance économique mais l'auto de
conscience écologique
je veux pas un business plan avec des
indicateurs de performance je veux un
bien-être plan avec des indicateurs de
bienveillance je peins un produit
intérieur brut al juin bonheur intérieur
brut
je pars un progrès sur un projet commun
je pas une survie j'ai une vie pas une
économie virtuelle une économie
virtuelle avec un certain degré oui
d'éveil spirituel
parce que faudra d'abord se changer soi
pour ensuite pouvoir prétendre changer
le monde et incarner ce que l'on dit est
ce que l'on vit et pas en théorie mais
en notre âme et conscience
être libre sans ego est alors pourquoi
pas soyons est un sou vent et réalisons
fait possible on dit souvent que
l'important ce n'est pas la chute mais
l'atterrissage
moi je pense que l'important c'est pas
la lune mais le métissage
donc oui il était d' il est temps
d'écrire demain et d'imaginer un nouveau
récit pour le futur et pour ça
j'aimerais invoqué le ou la poétique
redessiné un cap dans un coup d'état
d'âme poétique une co écriture de notre
avenir politique
moi je suis un enfant du monde un jeune
de l'univers
je me suis donné comme mission de
contribuer arts poétiques et la société
et de réenchanter l'avenir
et c'est ça ma part en tant que co est
une petite rim pour l'homme un avenir
politique pour l'humanité au capitaine
mon capitaine
gardons le cap silence m pour
transcender le système avec un je t'aime
la poésie pour moi c'est un élan
d'optimisme vers l'avenir
c'est un voyage spatio temporelle dans
l'inconnu dans l'au delà
c'est une symphonie humaniste des
mélodies de nos vies c'est un art
imaginaire visionnaire
c'est un art thérapeute sic et utopique
hyperpuissant où la vie elle même est
une poésie dans laquelle chaque être
humain est une petite note de musique
qui essayent de s'accorder en harmonie
avec la partition terrestre de
l'humanité à l'intérieur de la symphonie
bienveillante du vivant et c'est aussi
notre champ lexical qui est le socle
commun de notre dialogue à la fois pour
notre communication vous trouvez cette
parole juste et aussi en termes
d'inspiration pour dessiner de nouveaux
horizons contempler l'idéal dans le
champ des possibles voir le beau le
subtil l'invisible la beauté de la
nature la bonté de l'être humain
wehrling et y avait cette phrase
absolument magique sur la crise il est
que la poésie c'est la voie de la
quatrième personne du singulier c'est ça
pour moi le trait d'union entre le je et
le nous en grec ancien poésie ça veut
dire créer faire donc le poète c'est pas
juste un rêveur c'est un acteur du
changement c'est un créateur de nouveau
monde et on a tous une âme de poète
suffit juste de la réveiller pour
sublimer sa condition habiter
poétiquement le monde être poète de sa
vie c'est toucher à l'essentiel est
plongé dans l'âme universel cette
connecter aux sources de l'être pour
libérer sa voix et le poétique c'est pas
juste d'écrire des vers
ceux-ci de vivre ses rêves john lennon
disait que un rêve qu'on rêve seul et
seulement un rêve un rêve qu'on rêve
ensemble est une réalité
donc si on partage tous ce même rêve
pourquoi ce qu'on ne mettrait pas en
place dès aujourd'hui on est oui arrivé
dans des navires différents mais on est
ensemble aujourd'hui dans le même wagon
le navire de l'avenir c'est pas le
titanic en train de couler c'est
l'harmonie au pied en train de voguer
c'est pas l'arche de noé mais l'arche de
nos rêves
et ça pour moi la véritable start up de
l'avenir avec des actionnaires mais des
pères complémentaires signataires où
tout le monde peut être recrutés pour
réenchanter un monde en chantier et
redonner un sens au mot plein emploi
avec chacun sa zone de talent sa mission
de vie en mettant son coeur à l'ouvragé
dans son corps de métier en faisant
appel à nos âmes de construction massive
pour l'avenir on est tous des artisans
de l'avenir chacun en mettant sa pierre
à l'édifice dans le même sens on est
tous au final en fait des résidents du
monde de demain et la société civile
ça reste la plus grosse force vive de
l'humanité la bonne nouvelle c'est que
les solutions existent déjà par deux des
process d'intelligence collective
la sobriété heureuse les démocraties
ouverte l'éducation positive l'éveil
spirituel ou pour créer une équipe
nouvelle économie mondiale soit une
économie virtuelle avec des nations
unies vers l'avenir et pas avec un
conseil de sécurité un conseil de sages
pour donner une direction
pas dans le sens dirigé dans le sens
dessiner un horizon c'est ça pour moi le
véritable génie humain au service de
l'avenir
cette langue universelle ce compromis ce
wind win pour créer une société humaine
où il fait bon vivre
ce pacte global impact local
cet accord mondial dans l'intérêt
général
en tant que nouvelle quête du graal
partout dans le monde aujourd'hui la
société civile se mobilisent s'organise
s'unissent early pour des jours plus
heureux que l'avenir est en nous la
solution viendra pas d'ailleurs leur a
pas d'homme providentiel je pense qu'au
final le messie c'est nous ensemble
avançant dans le même sens ce qu'on est
tous des citoyens du monde
et d'ailleurs quand on regarde dans le
mot humanité il ya toujours eu ce mot
caché de l'unité juteux lire entre les
rayons pour finir sachez que rien
n'arrête un rêve dont la passion a germé
j'ai pas les acteurs ou les rêveurs
change de monde ces deux ensembles les
passionnés ceux qui ont l'audace la
détermination la persévérance créer leur
propre chemin durable et si on partage
tout cette passion commune pour la vie
et pour l'avenir
plus rien ne nous ne l'arrêtera donc oui
les ted
il est temps d'embrasser notre destin
commun sur un chemin humain on est tous
des rédacteurs du changement dans
l'avenir avec un grand a
donc soyez des rebelles qui donnait vie
à vos rêves en libérant le mozart le
prépare qui sommeille en vous dans
l'étincelle de brunel avec votre part de
bonté d'humanité et de colibri au
service de l'avenir
et soyons cette génération h cette
génération de l'harmonie
de l'hymne de l'humain les horizons de
l'harmonie c'est le gars dit oui à la
vie
oui à l'avenir oui à l'utopie parce que
bien sûr tout est possible et l'être
humain est bien plus magique qu'on
imagine finale même si la vie ne vaut
rien rien ne vaut la vie
j'ai vu ce j'ai ressenti ce miracle de
la vie
le jour où je suis devenu père parce que
j'ai vu comment l'amour se transmettait
de génération en génération à neutrons
pour ça que j'ai la foi en l'être humain
et en l'avenir
ma femme et ma fille aujourd'hui sont
les deux belles poésies ghm est donc
grandissant en humanité et plus sont la
condition humaine même si l'humanité on
lui demande pas sa main on lui offre
demain cette poésie je la dédie à
l'arc-en-ciel coloris la grâce de chaque
être humain par l'avenir réside dans
l'harmonie d'une partition à 15
milliards demain on change de monde avec
des si mais surtout avec des je t'aime
même thème regardez chimie de l'amour
dans un pot et ça fait un poème
m nous prenons ce soir une belle photo
de famille humaine men ben parce qu on a
que l'amour disait jacques brel la vie
est belle belle belle et peut-être que
tout cela n'était pas un rêve mais juste
le futur jardin d'éden denver chercher
l'harmonie et vous trouverez le bonheur
de rvi cherchons l'harmonie et on
trouvera le paradis ici
merci mon voyage vers l'avenir
[Applaudissements]